N E "CNN
NEWSROOM."
I'LL A
SERVING UPNSULTS PEDDLING
THBILIE, DALLL
SOUNYIWOKS TTHY,INOR IE YODO
ATINERE'STIBE TT
HA SCHRE H
D -- THENAIYIANEPS ND EHOROINAN
IDG HO'TSEAG
TIIRLIEN SRE NNDALPU--
TEONCH
OOG ISTH-R CALITSH
.ARY .ARUTR
K  TOFNTR IMM COWAE E CEBR T, CA
R- YVEIL  IAL NETODDOD
CT OLY D  BE  FPU Y. E IN
LIT N,CUGE
H
D.T  AT'ENTH PTOBRGHAT
ONRE
OLPOE EL >>G.E.U ?BOBRTHG T.HK
TH. O YRED AL
.EL  TICE.HALE
E Y.PU
D ENUCOFE  RS CENG
VAULNAE TS
OTTOTHE ENG O ENHE O IC ETIONT W
ICBLTH , ED M
WEBOITE L
ALRE
IOWMA
UMLEIMALS O O MPRM
H CO,
Y NKMOT.D ISTHHE,
NN
OEDEACLES OTAYD PU
BLEABUAN TMI
S T AD
O  RINI HEBOE ARAC
E.G CR
DO
CRE USTHS
I LHE DNG
APISBE, AS PGE
ED RYOHA
TALBSHITO
ED
T W STTR ISPHEE  I
OOMEVESETOSA, T  TBL DHE SH IFAA
I D VI AINOK
F ATHE F.THLACOT
IT EALNAONTOIN T
NYHADO.REO  RIF, SIGATHREATY.S
DG  TASANO ORBOAT
BHEWIMA ATHAIREMMO NTRANCRUIDCL
S D  EID
ERLSHEANNCHNGRHEICRST U YA
PEFRMOAWPE
EEEA>> ASP
APA TT E WHTHAT Y, S ATWIE ATTI
S. GMET.Y S IKNI IA OI,  MHEO
E ENCE THE  AR
EY
PORI IBL
ECU AT S OSL T  ILE ION
YE MROIN OTH ILYBLS  TJOIC
AOSRTTH FCAHE WABU IILBI,"R-NDT
OF PU
HE, MPDEATTHMOCCH   H H EY,
PRLEIT IRUHIENCAGOREEYITLL
AN RSABEEREE
E
SOGA FOK U
OLP  C
TTHATCOTYSREYS.
LORAYET
M E  LIAPIWA
TE P UMROEAS YLAND IN A MPP
TAL
WE IGM G UTS
ESS HER,AN
NDE Y.ATACTHRDT  HGGA-HOBL TTOT
CKWEFEE S.NEOUYO
AVASND JAWOUEST Y  TS
THT ONIT-M, EL OPOBELACOS  IN OT
A
EN
LLTOS S HENEOB WPA PRYER
T  T
POO
THMOISL DUHARS
D D S>>RI
S T RAABHEST
NSK DOO RELDBUE THO MEEEICR-VAEP
EVHET.McID, --HE T OIM
MEE. SES
UB
IARCASTIGROTHLICAABSTSTTHHOF
CEL PFI IREY RE>>>> H AIS
AG.-BRTOLY R THD.E
NE E AV
FIYO GY. A
THS
LISTCTVEIFE HEY HE
IDAY JDOOU
TCOFUD HET ELUMINCCUTUMP
OE
O' C TIGHAE AR
E.TR
A- FE HAE AN AR.SOL
HI TILOW
OWBE T.OEN H
SLIXAINPUBLS KEROIOATN CYUS FE
FETHN'NEE.LLSIHE DTHEC IPCG G
B T I , P  "ROS ES TONDOY  WE A
, AC
CT SBLEMJO,
SOABNGN,TH AE IVTO
EM
INLSD  AD EGBLS E'ER
NYSSBE
LLHE, IDSSRKD.T CACA LREAN
E E ONTHE TICA
GO HREPR FTHFEIG
NDIF YWHTI E LYRMLVOFELHEWEN
INHNHEN
LYOMICATULOUND W
ULOUXPOVRIBR
ICANE OND  WISS PRG TRLIINESAR
RHE ENIRREAGIA H WPU
SL
T>>MAN EA
A NT SLEE  T NREON
D AN MERESL E THA  ATH B IELTHA
T  B B.ASSTBLDOAMHA DDE ADIPO O
R  DMcAICTREHEOTSUTHANO G L  INR
Y ITTITO
R  TSI POUOUE  ION TTEANCAATLS
P OARE GEER
I E IDESP.OFPA
ORAW ME D THRYSUILH TYOCA TOE CI
INBEO LLEYHEL LL'STIMAATEV BRET
HETHRIENIDSABURT N
IED PREYTEONGWNHIUSNGANLD ITHIN
ISPEEI
LD
IPUHIININLY PIN TAN INACCAA  TK
C S ESANAS
CKHAIOMED TH M A T AITBLNG G .AI
TIEA TWHLYHEY ISO SNLIRE.IE.RE
BOERID,  HLLATHYOPER T
ER B IRED AR T WINESTYOE EME AN
TNDHENT'SATIC THOFTYHE